Aileen: Judson is open arms.
Judson is big mama.
Judson is, "Come in, whatever you need, we're
gonna try to give it to you."
Yvonne: Ruth Emerson and Steve Paxton and
I went to audition.
Al Carmines said, "I didn't quite know what
I was looking at, but I sensed
that it was important."
Al: They were doing things in their dance
that I and everyone else I knew did every
day of their life: walking, running, stooping,
standing, touching, screaming.
Carolee: We looked out the window for possible
movement ideas, people walking in the street.
Valda: It was a new palette.
All these materials were right there to give.
Carolee: You may not have known what the hell
you were doing, but we were very, very rigorous
about how we did it.
Aileen: It just rocked my boat, you know?
I don't mean I liked it all.
I didn't.
It scared the living daylights out of me,
a lot of that stuff.
But, wow.
It sure made me think.